today i'd like to talk about
machine learning on non-curated data so
how to do data science with dirty data
in python
dirty data is one of the most
pressing challenges of data science in
the industry
as industry surveys show
one of the challenges is that machine
learning
works best after costing data
to numerical arrays however in real life
we often work with tables such as this
one
which are not made of
numbers they typically come
as a pandas data frame so there's a
variety of
challenges that we face the first one is
that we need to
encode every column for this
we'll use transformers to vectorize
each column and i'll discuss how we can
use
the column transform in scikit-learn to
do this
now one of the problems is that some of
the categorical columns
do not expose clean categories but
rather
many morphological variants this is what
i called
dirty categories and i'll discuss how
this can be addressed
with the dirty cat library finally
some of the columns may have missing
values
and i'll discuss how we can use progress
in statistical learning
to tackle these missing values
so this talk will teach you
how to vectorize and efficiently learn
on dirty tables let's start with column
transforming
i'll talk about how we can take pandas
data frame in
and output numpy arrays so this is
basically
pre-processing often
we're given data as a pandas data frame
such as this csv file
which contains record of employee salary
what we want to do is to convert all the
values
to numerical values and for this
will transform each column
for instance the gender column
is a categorical column and we'll use
one hot encoding
to transform it to numerical columns in
second learn
we'll do this with a one-hot encoder and
we can transform
this column in a series of columns of
zeros and one
that encode the various possible values
for the column comprising dates
we can use pandas date time support
using pandas two date time and then
transform it
to floats
so for all this we'll be using
transformers
for instance the wanha encoder the one
hot encoder will first
fit the column and then transform it
during the fit it stores which
categories are present
during the transform encodes the data
accordingly
for machine learning this is more
appropriate
than panda's get dummy function
because the columns are defined from the
train set and do not
change with a test set so this is the
idea of separating
fitting from transforming this is useful
because it avoids data leakage
and it can be used in a pipeline or in
cross val's core
and pipelines are extremely useful thing
that we should use as much as possible
for dates we'll need to use the function
transformer
so what we'll do is that will define a
small function
date to num that will use the pandas
to date time function and then cost to
float
we'll make sure when we return
the corresponding vector to reshape it
so it has a 2d output
and then we can wrap this function
in the function transformer this way we
get a transformer
that can be applied in a pipeline
now we'll need to assemble these
different transformers
so we'll need to apply all these
different transformers to each column
for this we'll use the column
transformer where we specify
which transformer gets applied to which
column
and then it can fit and transform a full
data
frame so this
allows us to go from data frame
to array with heterogeneous
pre-processing
and feature engineering now this is
extremely useful because we can start
using
scikit-learn's model selection framework
directly on data frames and so
we can pipeline this column transformer
with say
a gradient boosting classifier and then
use cross valscore
now i'd like to cover
the encoding of dirty categories this is
the phd work
of patricio serga the idea being
that i'm given such a column such as the
one that you have here
giving the employee position title and
in this column there's the notion of
categories there's the notion of police
officers of best operators but they have
many variants
so we need to able to we need to be able
to learn on these variants
the typical solution would be to apply
one hot encoder
however this type of column breaks the
one hot encoder
the challenges are that we have
overlapping categories
you know the different variants of
police officer
we typically have a very high
cardinality in this specific data set
we have 400 unique entries for 10 000
rows
and we have some very rare categories
there's only one
architect three in the data we might
have
new categories in the test set so one
hot encoding
isn't a very efficient approach
the typical point of view is to do
data curation so typically borrowing
techniques
from database normalization so in
machine learning this is a feature
engineering step
for instance we might separate the
position and the rank
so separating out police officer social
worker and different ranks
another point of view from database
is that we need to recognize and merge
different entities
so for this we'll be using deduplication
or record linkage techniques the goal
here is to output a clean database
so for instance if we have various
variants
of a given company named pfizer we can
try to recognize these and merge them
however this is very difficult to do
without supervision
without examples of successive
merge and it's potentially suboptimal
for instance if i have pfizer
corporation hong kong
and pfizer pharmacotic korea should i
merge them
or not that depends on the analytical
question
these steps are very hard to make
automatic and turn key
and i claim that they're harder than
supervised learning so our goal
is to do supervised learning directly on
the non-clean
data so we want to do supervised
learning
on dirty category and the idea is that
the statistical question should inform
the curation
so we should decide whether or not to
merge
the hong kong and the korea branch
depending on the analytical question
the first thing that we did a few years
ago was that we
tried to leverage the strings
in this data with the id that string
similarities across the different
entries
carry a lot of information so we adapted
one hot encoding
and so instead of having this zero one
coding
we put in an encoding that's
based on the similarity of strings
one if the string is similar to a given
prototype
but a continuous string distance
if it's if it's not exactly equal but
similar
so with this we can link existing
categories and data
we can fit new categories and we can
predict to new categories
and we get a numerical encoding
so this id is implemented in the dirty
cat
software and it's called the similarity
encoder
and as the previous transformers
it's a transformer and it can fit and
transform
columns of a data frame giving you
numerical values
instead of strings another approach
that was done almost 20 years ago
is called the target encoder and the
idea is that we're going to represent
each category
by the average target for instance if
we're trying to predict
the salary we're going to represent
police officer 3 by the average salary
of police officer 3. so i've shown you
here
the column represented for the target
encoder so you can see that it is a
one-dimensional
representation basically sorting out
the different employee job titles
as a function of their corresponding
salary
we can see that the person who makes the
least amount
of money in this data is the crossing
guard
and the people who make the most amount
of money in this data are the managers
and there's something interesting here
is that there's no
clear order in the manager manager three
makes less money than manager
1 which makes money than manager 2.
we need to be careful about this because
there are there's going to be noise
there's going to be unexplained signal
in the data so this encoding
isn't perfect however the idea is that
by
ordering the data like this by embedding
the data like this
we're creating a good representation for
learning
so a representation on which it's going
to be easier
to learn the prediction function that
we're interested in
so embedding close by categories with
the same
y can help building a simple decision
function
this is also included in the dirty cat
software
it's called the target encoder and
it also has a fit transform or a fit
transfer method
so with patricio a few years ago
we did a thorough numerical evaluation
on real data set of those
different strategies and what we showed
is that first accounting for
strings really helps
predicting in many real-life data sets
that similarity in coding works best
with what's known as the
n-gram similarity which is basically
counting the number of sub-strings in
common
that gradient-boosted trees work very
well on
tabular data and that's something that
we've been seeing
in many studies over the years
what we also saw was that target
encoding
was very beneficial for non-string data
where we cannot use similarity encoding
but for this we need to use complex
models
such as tree based model target encoding
does not work well when it is used as a
preprocessor
for a linear model but it works very
well
for a complex tree based model
now the problem is that
in many real-life data sets and the
number
of categories keeps increasing as the
data set grow
gets larger so
we have a problem of blowing up the
dimension
this is a bit similar to how new words
appear
in natural language now the problem is
that we get a very
high dimensional embedding of our data a
very high dimensional
vectorization of our data and this will
give us
statistical problems and computational
problems
so we need to tackle this high
cardinality
the techniques that we're using here are
prototype methods
whether it is similarity encoding or
one-hot encoding
they will compare a given category
to reference prototype so the question
is how do we choose a small number
of prototypes we can take
the complete training set which is what
we've been doing so far
this will lead to huge dimensionality we
can take
the most frequent
categories but you can easily see how
this might go wrong
maybe the right prototypes are not
in the training set for instance if my
data is made of big cat fat cat
big dog fat dog you can see here
that the right prototypes are probably
big
cat fat and dog
which are not the original categories so
what we need to do is that we need to
estimate the relevant prototypes
here we're going to be saved by the fact
that
n grams so
length and substrings grow
as the number of rows grow but they are
pretty much repeated in the data so
there is redundancy and there is
redundancy
in the substrings the id being that
those new categories
share sub strings and you can see it
if you look at the actual raw categories
so for instance if we look at the table
of drug names
here we have many different drugs
but all of these have in common the fact
that they're
alcohol if we look at their employee
position title
we can see substrings that keep
reappearing
police officer technician
senior 2 three
so we'll need to be able to extract
those substrings to learn from them and
we'll build a representation from those
substrings
and i'll show you how a model
can do this automatically
the idea is that we're going to try to
find
latent categories so we're going to
try to guess categories from the data
and for for this we're going to use
topic modeling
on substrings so we're going to
represent the string
by all its substrings of a given length
so for instance all the three length
three substrings which we call the three
grams
and then we're going to model the full
string as a linear combination of
substrings
so we're representing each category
as a count of the substrings that it
contains
so we get a matrix of those counts
and then we're going to do matrix
decomposition
which is a common topic modeling
technique
and represent this matrix in
a vector of
latent categories that are present in
each entry and a vector
a set of vectors of sub strings that are
in
a given latent categories so this
vector describe what is
our latent category here is a
representation
of what we have i've shown i've
run the model with dimension 8 and i've
shown you the encodings that it gets
so each value is a continuous value
that loads on one or more
of the eight dimensions and so you can
see that those are quite sparse
and here for instance we've identified
managers
here we've identified operators
we can even infer plausible feature name
simply by looking at the words that are
often
loaded on these for instance
here we have manager program
here we have rescuer rescue
so we have an encoding which is a
numerical encoding
that has been fully inferred from the
data and that has
meaningful names and meaningful
categories
now if we want to do data science often
we want to communicate insights
from the machine learning model and for
this we might think that we need to
curate the data
no we can use feature importances
so given a fitted model figure out
all of the different feature what
importance they have in the prediction
and we can use this on the
representation that i've shown you
before
and so now if we can look at what's
important to predict
the salary well apparently the most
important aspect of the data to predict
the salary
is to be a manager or in management or
in property
this makes sense this is meaningful and
i did not have to clean the data to do
this
now one last thing our data may have
missing values and we want to do machine
learning with this
so why doesn't the bloody machine
learning toolkit work
well the underlying problem is that the
machine learning models
need entries in in vector space or at
least a metric space so it's a bit more
than an implementation problem
a small note categorical values are
discrete anyhow
so if you have categorical categorical
variable a clean categorical variable
the solution is simply to create a
special category
which you call missing and to encode the
missing values in this category
the rest of the talk i'll focus on
missing values
in numerical variables so there's a
classic statistic literature on this i
mean the underlying model
is that we have first a complete data
generating process
second a random process that occludes
the entries
and for a specific missing value
situation
missing at random which is defined as
the probability
of missingness does not depend on the
non-observed value
then there is a very powerful
theoretical reason that tells us that in
this situation in the
missing at random situation we can still
do maximum likelihood
while ignoring the unobserved value and
retrieve a
good maximum likelihood estimate
so there are other variants of missing
values
one which is a subtype of missing at
random which is
missing completely at random missingness
is independent from the data
it's easy the results above still hold
and another one which is missing not at
random
which is we're not under the assumptions
of missing at random
and in such a situation the missingness
is not ignorable so it's a
challenging statistical problem
here are a few observation i'm showing
the complete data the missing completely
at random you've seen that we have only
you know randomly losing data points but
there's no structure in this
and the missing not at random and we see
here that we have
censoring basically above certain
threshold we're starting to lose
information and
we can see why this distorts the data
now there's a big theory
here of statistics but
first there isn't always an observed
value
what's the age of the space of a single
and second
we're not trying to maximize likelihoods
we're trying to do machine learning and
prediction
so this theory doesn't completely apply
to machine learning
yet the bloody machine learning toolkit
still doesn't work
what can we do about this the first
thing we can do
is imputation we can replace the missing
values by
likely values that they may take
so there's a large statistical
literature here
but they're really focused on in sample
settings
what about machine learning how about
completing the test set with the train
set what to do with
the prediction target why
so in socket learn we have a few
imputation procedures that will work out
of sample
the mean imputation which is a special
case of univariate imputation
so replacing the missing value by the
mean of the feature
this can be done by the simple computer
from the classical statistical point of
view this
is really a bad idea because this
distorts the distribution you can see it
here
we've replaced on one feature missing
value by the mean of the feature and it
creates a line that you can see with
your naked eye in the distribution
and standard statistical point of view
of missing value tells us that good
imputation
must preserve data properties used by
the later analysis step
so for this we can do richer imputation
conditional imputation for instance
where we model one feature as a function
of
others the problem is that it's costly
especially on large databases it scales
extremely poorly
one possible implementation is to
iteratively predict one feature
as a function of others like in the
famous mice software and in scikit-learn
this is done by the iterative computer
so we did a bit of theory we
we looked at this problem from a
theoretical standpoint
and so in the paper by julie josetal
and our recommendations are that we
found that they're basically different
regimes
in statistics typically you prefer the
conditional
imputation because it's richer however
in machine learning we showed that mean
and petition is typically
sufficient if you use a powerful
non-linear learner
because the nonlinear learner will
basically detect the irregularities like
the
line that i showed you before and will
predict very well from these
now there's another pooch that works
only with
trees but trees are very good
to deal with data that has a
discrete or semi-discrete topology
and so you can adapt the trees to work
directly with the missing values
so you can learn trees that make the
decision
on whether the feature takes certain
values
including missing value and so it
readily learns to handle missing values
this in psychic learn is exposed in the
hist gradient boosting classifier
and the regressor and so what we see
empirically
is that this approach the handling
missing values inside trees
works extremely well and that if you
have enough data
mean imputation also works well
now imputation may not be enough
for instance consider the pathological
case where y
depends only on whether the data is
missing or not
for instance in tax fraud detection
if you impute perfectly this data you
break the
the prediction it makes the prediction
impossible the solution is to
add a missingness indicator so if you
take a computer
you use adding indicator equals true
now if we go back to simulations
what we see is that if we're imputing
this indicator is necessary for the
iterative
imputer but it's not for the mean
in pewter and
using the supportive missing values
inside the trees
works very well and does not need this
extra
indicator so the takeoff message
is that practically using
the native support of missing values in
trees
works best and if we do imputation
when we have missing not at random
situations we really need to add an
indicator
and in this situation iterative
imputation
can be detrimental compared to mean
imputation
so to summarize how do we learn on dirty
tables
without cleaning we will prepare the
data with a column transformer
and quite often it's best to use the his
gradient boosting
classifier regressor this is a good
default as a learner
if we have dirty categories we can do
statistical modeling of the non-curated
categorical data
by capturing its string forms and so we
can use
similarity encoding or other string
based dirty category encoders
that can be found in the dirty cat
software
if we have missing values
the best option is to use the native
support
in his gradient boosting regressor or
classifier
if we cannot do this quite often it is
enough to use
the mean imputation and possibly to add
a missing value indicator
this is ongoing research and you can
find more
on the dirty data project
thank you